>> John Haskell:
I'm John Haskell
and I'm the director
of the Kluge Center.
And I know that there's a
lot of people I haven't seen
at our events before,
so I'll let you know.
And maybe a good refresher
for those of you who have come
to our events, what our
mission is at the Kluge Center,
which is located
through that wall here
in the Jefferson Building.
The mission as established in
the charter that was in 2000 is
to reinvigorate the
interconnection
between thought and action.
That's how the charter puts it.
So it's the bridge between
scholarship on the one hand
and the policymakers like the
people in Congress and elsewhere
in Washington and the
interested public on the other.
So to that end, we at the
Kluge Center bring some
of the world's great scholars
to the library to make use
of the collections and
engage in conversations
that address the
challenges facing democracies
in this century.
In this event, the Kluge Center
in conjunction with the Center
for Women in Politics and
the Center for Congressional
and Presidential Studies
at American University are
bringing together practitioners
and scholars in an effort to
shed some analytical rigor
and insight on the
upcoming midterm elections.
As you probably know, the entire
House as well as about one-third
of the Senate is up this year,
which means that power
is in the balance.
The balance of power will be
determined by the election.
So of course it's
extremely important.
So we're going to go through
some topics here with respect
to the elections for the
next 40 minutes or so.
And then we'll leave
time before the reception
which you're all welcome
to for some questions
from the audience.
Let me start by introducing
our panel.
Sara Fagen is immediately
here to my left,
is one of the nation's leading
political and issue strategists
at DDC Public Affairs where
she became a partner in 2011.
She was a senior aide and
White House political director
to President George W. Bush.
The word wunderkind, which
some of you may know --
I'm not pronouncing the
German right, I know --
was created for people
like Sara.
This is not on her webpage.
I can attest to this personally
because I've known Sara
for longer than either of us
probably want to talk about.
She gained a high-level
position in the White House
in the presidential campaign
before she was 25 years old.
And in the White House she was
deputy political director well
before she was 30.
We're not going to get too
specific other than that,
because that would be rude.
The Wall Street Journal
describes her as one
of the people who perfected
political microtargeting.
You can see her commentary
on a regular basis on CNBC.
Dr. Elaine Kamarck.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Kamarck.
>> John Haskell: I knew that.
I even know her daughter-in-law
who works at the library.
Is a senior fellow in the
governance studies program
as well as director
of the Center
for Effective Public Management
at the Brookings Institution.
Elaine is an expert on
American electoral politics
and government innovation
and reform.
Her research focuses
on the party system
and the presidential
nomination system.
She's the author of
several books including
"How Change Happens or Doesn't:
The Politics of US
Public Policy."
She's a lecturer
in public policy
for over the last 20 years at
the Harvard Kennedy School.
Previously she helped spearhead
the new Democrat movement
in the 1980's and worked
in the Clinton White House
and has been a member of the DNC
and the DNC's rules
committee for over 20 years.
And she's also been a five-time
super-delegate which kind
of got a little more
attention a couple of years ago
than it had in the past.
She makes regular appearances
-- am I supposed to say that?
I pulled it right off your --
>> Elaine Kamarck:
It's all right.
>> John Haskell: She
makes regular appearances
on all the major media.
David Barker is professor of
government and he's the director
of the Center for Congressional
and Presidential Studies
at American University.
He's the author of
numerous articles and books.
Please take special note
of his upcoming Oxford
University Press book,
"One Nation, Two Realities."
I've already read most of it,
even though it's not out yet.
"Dueling Facts in
American Democracy."
And by the way, there
will be a book even there
at the Kluge Center
early next year.
It really is fascinating.
So we're going to jump
right into starting to think
about in an analytical way
congressional elections
in general, in particular
midterm elections.
So I want to hit some
generic things first.
And I'm going to start
with David at that end.
In beginning any analysis
of midterm elections,
forget about that
we're in 2018 --
just anyone on a
generic standpoint --
what are the key factors that
you take into consideration?
[ Inaudible ]
>> David Barker: Historically,
a president with
an approval rating
under 50 traditionally
loses a lot of seats.
The average is in the 40s.
And indeed, all presidents
except three in the history
of the United States have
lost seats during midterms.
So you start there.
Another thing that you
want to take a look
at is the state of the economy.
This is an unusual year because
we have a very strong economy
and a very unpopular president.
So that statistic that I
mentioned a second ago,
where unpopular presidents
tend to translate
into big seat losses, typically
those unpopular presidents are
partially unpopular because of
a downward-trending economy.
So this is a really unusual
year and it's going to be a test
of these competing theories
as to presidential approval
and economic factors.
Just a third thing
that I'll mention
that is important is
the size of the victory
by the president
two years earlier.
So typically really big
midterm losses correspond
to big coattails
two years earlier.
So when there's a big
victory like in 1964, 1972,
to a lesser extent 1992
or 2008, then you tend
to see the big loss two
years later because a lot
of people are swept
in on the coattails.
We obviously don't have
that situation this time.
>> John Haskell: Elaine,
what would you add to that?
What do you look
at, irrespective
of the particular year?
>> Elaine Kamarck: Well,
let me dig deeper on one
of the points you made.
Midterm elections
are not always,
always about the
presidential candidate
or the president rather.
It varies.
And we've had midterm elections
that are really local, you know.
It's just what the local issues
are, who's running, et cetera.
But increasingly we seem to have
what the political scientists
call nationalized
midterm elections.
We've just in recent years
-- 2006 was nationalized.
2010 was nationalized.
And this one looks to be a
heavily nationalized election.
Now one of the reasons that
this happens is you've got
to think about it this way.
People who are in the
business of politics have --
they're planning their careers
in a long-term fashion
the way you would
in your business, right?
And so if you're sitting around
in 2017 and you're looking
at this president's
kind of bumbling along
and having a hard time
getting his footing, et cetera,
and you're a county
commissioner someplace
and you've always wanted
to run for congress.
You say, "Hmm, this
year I'm getting in."
Okay? Because this year might
be a good year for my party.
And if you were sitting
around in Congress in 2009
as Barack Obama ran
into problems getting
out of the recession and his
healthcare bill, et cetera,
you might say, "Good year for
me, a Republican, to get it."
So what intermediates this
phenomenon is something we call
quality candidates.
So good candidates, people
with a base in the district,
know something about the
business for running for office,
can raise money, et cetera,
they tend to get in in years
when it's looking
good for their party.
And we see some evidence
of that this time
around on the Democratic side.
The converse of that is,
if you're a Republican
and you're sitting around
in 2017 or Democrat sitting
around in 2009, you
say to yourself,
"Maybe it's time I retired.
Maybe it's time I went and
became a lobbyist and made money
or did something else."
>> John Haskell: Spend
more time with my children.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Spend
That's a good one.
>> John Haskell: Sara,
what would you add to that?
And also, maybe you
could speak to --
neither of them said the magic
word money or campaign finance,
so maybe you can speak to that.
But what else would you add?
>> Sara Fagen: Well, I think you
know, adding to those points,
I would add two things
that I would look for.
One is the enthusiasm gap.
And that plays out
in many forms.
In self-reported polls we've
seen in this election Democrats
for virtually the entire cycle
have had a significantly higher
level of enthusiasm
over the Republicans.
The enthusiasm gap has
been higher for Democrats.
In 2010 and 2014, Republicans
had a significantly higher gap
over the Democrats and of
course they did very well
in those midterms.
I always look at
the generic ballot.
I think it tends to be
a little less effective
than it was 15 years ago.
There are so many other
things to measure.
But the generic ballot which is
a self-reported polling question
where they say, you know,
they're getting rid of the names
of the irrespective candidates.
Would you be more likely
to vote for the Democratic
or the Republican candidate?
And Democrats have had --
you know, I would say
roughly an 8-12-point lead
in the generic ballot
most of this cycle,
even prior to the recent
Supreme Court frontpage news.
So those are two other
things I look at.
And then of course
money does matter,
although money is
increasingly less important.
And it's much less important
when the election
is nationalized.
And I agree a lot with Elaine.
We've had a series -- five
of the last six elections
have been change elections.
The last three midterms
were change elections.
This appears to be
a change election.
We're in a period of enormous
political tumult in this country
that has a lot more
to do with --
if you sort of think back
about the rapid pace of change
in society over the
last 20 or 30 years.
Quickening pace of change.
Technology, finance, the way
wars are fought in this country,
significant demographic changes.
There's a lot underlying
our politics.
Donald Trump is a symptom of
the times, not the opposite way.
And so I think a lot of those
factors mean we're going
to have a nationalized election.
And you know, money is
going to be less important.
There are going to
be people who lose.
Incumbents with more
money are going to lose
because of the nationalized
nature of this election.
>> John Haskell: David, you
wanted to add something.
>> David Barker: Yeah, I
just wanted to add something
on the campaign finance which
is that money is important
but it's really a threshold.
There are diminishing
returns to it.
So you have to have a certain
amount of money to be able
to run an effective campaign and
put ads out there and have staff
and all that kind of
stuff that you need
to do just to be competitive.
But once you get above that
threshold of competitiveness,
then you can raise $50 million
more and it's not going to make
that much of a difference.
In fact, it's frequently
the case that the candidate
who raises and spends
more money loses.
And I mean, this is a panel
about midterm elections,
but if we want one example
of that, we can look to 2016
when Clinton outraised
and outspent Trump
by a very significant margin
and that didn't really
matter to much.
>> Sara Fagen: One final point
on money, the higher the office,
the less impactful dollars are.
>> Elaine Kamarck:
That's a good point, yeah.
>> Sara Fagen: And
I agree with David,
that oftentimes money
isn't relevant.
But in the Senate races, in a
midterm that's not nationalized,
money matters a lot more than it
does I think in a year like this
where the whole country
appears to be paying attention
to Donald Trump's Twitter feed.
>> John Haskell: So Elaine
and Sara in particular harped
on the idea that the election
is more nationalized and it used
to be you had a panel like this
and in the first five minutes
somebody would say, "Well,
all politics is local."
They'd quote Tip O'Neil
and then they'd quit and go
to questions and the reception.
But it's different now.
And I was looking up some
statistics in preparing for this
and I noticed that in 1988,
over 40% of the House seats
in those districts, over 40% of
them went or different parties
for president and for the House.
And that's a Dukakis -- for
those of you who don't remember
or weren't alive,
Dukakis lost pretty badly
to then Vice President Bush,
but the Democrats maintained
the House quite easily in fact
when you look at it in
the sweep of history.
And nowadays it's like there are
a few seats that are like that,
that regularly split tickets.
Where a lot of people
are splitting tickets
which yielded the kind of
result I described in 1988.
So let's just nail it down.
What specific has
changed and how does
that affect our analysis
this time?
You guys have sort of touched
on it, but let's get specific.
Elaine, do you want
to tackle that?
>> Elaine Kamarck: Yeah,
well first thing to say
on that is there
are 24 House seats
that Hillary Clinton won the
district and the Republican won.
And if you look at those,
most of them are you know,
right in the bull's eye
where the Democrats are
concentrating their efforts
to try to take back those seats.
>> John Haskell: That's
as compared to 200
that were like that in 1988.
Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: That's right.
Many, many fewer.
I think that there's a
couple of structural changes.
I think one is, interestingly
enough, the disappearance
of local newspapers and the
diminishment of local news.
So you can't have a localized
race if nobody's reporting
on local issues, right?
And we at Brookings have a big
project called The Primaries
Project, for those of
you interested in it.
We're publishing lots
of papers and we're
about to publish
three major reports.
And what we do in that is we
code people's websites, okay?
And we don't even take a sample.
We do the whole universe,
all the Republicans,
all the Democrats who run.
And we look at their websites.
And what's interesting is how
little variation there is,
right?
The Republicans talk about
the same five or six things,
the Democrats talk about
the same five or six things.
There's very rarely local
issues on these websites.
Now we couldn't have done the
same research 20 years ago
because nobody had websites.
But I'm sure if you were able to
somehow have a standard measure
of candidate message
20-30 years ago,
we wouldn't have found that.
I think we would have found
a lot more local issues.
So between the non-reporting
of that and the absence
of a local press has
really helped I think
to further nationalize
these campaigns.
>> John Haskell: David?
>> David Barker: So
a couple of things.
First of all, to pick
up on the media aspect.
In addition to the
decline of local reporting
across the country, as
everybody in this room knows,
we've had an increase in
terms of partisan news, right?
And so starting in the '90s with
talk radio and then in cable
with Fox and MSNBC and
then with websites and then
with social media, increasingly
people get their news filtered
through partisan sources,
and that actually contributes
to the nationalization
of politics.
Because Rush Limbaugh
or Sean Hannity
or Rachel Madow don't
talk about local issues.
And that's where people get
their news, not from local.
Another couple of things I'll
mention is that over the course
of the past, I don't
know, ten years or so,
there have been two books
called "The Big Sort"
and they were talking
about different things.
But both of those sorts
are relevant here.
The first "big sort"
has to do with the fact
that it's mostly in
the south, right?
The formerly solid Democratic
south where you had really,
really conservative
democrats, right,
there used to be basically
three parties in this country:
national Republican party,
a northern Democratic party
and a southern Democratic party.
And the southern
Democratic party were the
most conservative.
Still as of 1988 there were lots
of conservative Democrats
in the south.
That has changed.
People have sorted themselves
ideologically, right?
And so now there are very
few conservative Democrats.
There are very few
liberal Republicans.
And that means you're going
to have fewer people balancing
their ticket or switching votes.
The other thing is the big sort
in terms of neighborhood sorting
or clustering or where
people live, right?
And so increasingly Republicans
and Democrats don't live
in the same cities or
towns or neighborhoods
or blocks like they used to.
I mean, Democrats increasingly
are clustered really
in a few heavily-concentrated
metropolitan areas on the coasts
and a few other places around,
college towns and et cetera.
Whereas Republicans
live everywhere else.
And so that along
with Gerrymandering has
created these districts
that are overwhelmingly
Democratic
or overwhelmingly Republican.
And in those sorts of
districts people are going
to vote along the party line.
>> John Haskell: So
where do Republicans live
in the Washington area, Sara?
[ Laughter ]
I'm teasing.
>> Sara Fagen: They hide.
[ Laughter ]
>> John Haskell: They don't
go to dinner, I understand.
Yeah. One example that
sort of illustrates some
of the things these
folks have said,
Sara's originally from Iowa.
And in 1994, which
we didn't know
at the time this was a trend,
but there was a congressman
who never was challenged going
all the way back 36 years named
Neil Smith.
And all he did every
time was explain, "Hey,
I'm on appropriation and
every building in Aims,
Iowa and every hospital in this
entire district has my name
on it.
Remember?"
And suddenly, based
on a national wave,
a plastic surgeon who's never
done any politics at all
and didn't particularly
have a tremendous amount
of political ability
beat him easily.
And that was -- looking back
on it, you're like, "Oh yeah,
that's the beginning of it."
But that happened a lot in 1994.
>> Sara Fagen: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: So one thing I
wanted to bring up with respect
to the generic ballot that
Sara brought up is like,
well, how useful is it?
You go on 538 and you
see Democrats are ahead
by this much.
I did a little research
on that and I looked back,
and if you go back to other
decades, even the first decade
of this century or further back,
you see that the overall
vote total in the House more
or less reflected what would
happen in the distribution
of House seats in
the general election.
So Democrats got 55% of the
two-party vote, get more
or less 55% of the seats.
What you see since 2010
is a very different thing
where now the commentary says,
"Hey, Democrats have to win
in the generic ballot or the
overall vote by at least seven
to be assure of winning."
What has happened?
What's the difference here?
>> Sara Fagen: Well,
you know, I think some
of it is the way
redistricting has happened.
And you know, we talked about
the self-sorting and so forth.
But if you sort of think through
partisan redistricting has
gotten more partisan
and Republicans have had
an important sort of thumb
on the scale, particularly
the last ten years,
just given their dominance.
Ironically, you know, for as
weak as Republicans may be
on the enthusiasm gap or
the generic balance today,
in many respects the party's
at a high watermark in terms
of the number of seats it holds.
>> John Haskell: Yep.
>> Sara Fagen: Governor seats,
state legislative chambers
that they have control of.
Of course control both chambers
of Congress across the street.
So partisan redistricting
has helped a lot with that.
I think if Democrats in fact
have a good year this year,
they'll be pretty
well set up heading
into the next decade
for redistricting.
And you'll see some of
that counterbalance.
And then also a lot
of it is turnout.
You know, in a presidential
year,
you'll get significantly
higher turnout of course.
And much of the Democratic base
are the folks that don't show
up in midterm elections.
They show up in presidential
elections.
But when you think of
where are the biggest gaps,
it tends to be single women,
minority voters, younger voters.
They tend to vote only in
presidential elections.
And so as a result, Republicans
have outperformed in midterms
because their older, whiter
voters tend to show up.
And they show up consistently.
So we'll see what
happens this year.
There's a lot of discussion
about the energized
Democratic base.
It's been like that
most of the year.
But historically speaking,
some of those groups
of voters have underperformed
in midterms.
>> John Haskell: David, you
were going to piggyback on that?
>> David Barker:
Yeah, so I just want
to mention two things
with respect to that.
The first is that the
group that I think for whom
that is the most true,
or the gap that is most
important there is the age gap.
There have been an awful lot
of progressive Democratic
candidates over the years
that have you know,
dreamed of winning big
because they were going
to turn out the youth.
And it just doesn't
really ever happen, right?
I mean, some of you may
remember Howard Dean,
is one name that comes to mind.
And even when they do, right,
I mean, young people turned
out in higher numbers
for Obama both times.
But the gap still between people
in their 20s or 30s and people
in their 50s, 60s and
older is enormous.
Now the other thing that I'll
say though is there is one
countervaling trend
to this general truism
that Republicans tend to
have a turnout advantage.
And that has been another
realignment if you want to say
with respect to education.
So one of the factors
that's most predictive
of turnout is education, right?
People with college degrees
and higher tend to turnout
at higher levels than
people who don't.
And you know, 40 years ago
Republicans had a big advantage
with college-educated voters.
20 years ago it was about even,
but Republicans still might
have had a slight advantage.
But now Democrats have a 22- or
23-percentage-poitn advantage
with college-educated voters.
They have a 33- or
35-percentage-point advantage
with voters who have
advanced degrees.
And so that may counter
the age gap and some
of the other gaps
that we talked about.
>> John Haskell: Elaine, yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Yeah.
And let me just do one
other thing on age.
Because Sara's absolutely
right on that.
The thing that keeps giving
Democrats hope is not just
hoping for bigger turnout.
But the different generations
are either bigger or smaller.
So us baby boomers, there
were a heck of a lot of us.
And to everybody's surprise,
we had a heck of a lot
of children called millennials.
The millennial generation
is the biggest generation
in American history.
So generations are
important when they're big.
>> John Haskell: Yep.
>> Elaine Kamarck: See, nobody
talks about the voting behavior
of gen X-ers, unfortunately
for those of you
who might be gen X-ers, right?
Because there just weren't
very many gen X-ers.
>> David Barker: And
we're tired and boring.
>> Elaine Kamarck: And
But when you have
a big generation,
when you have what we call
a pig in the python, right,
as that generation moves
through you know, you've got --
>> John Haskell: It
eventually comes out.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Yeah.
As that generation moves
through the electorate,
their voting behavior becomes
quite significant simply
because there's so many of them.
>> John Haskell: Less creative
people used to say lump
in a snake, so I'll
give you that one.
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Elaine.
>> Elaine Kamarck: That's okay.
And so what we know so far
about the millennial
generation is they have tended
to vote Democratic.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Okay,
they don't like to call
themselves, Democrats, right?
But it doesn't matter
when push comes to shove.
They vote Democratic.
Barack Obama's entire
margin of victory
in 2008 came from
people under 30.
Okay? If you had taken them out
of the equation, he was neck
and neck in all the
other age cohorts.
So it's not just
old versus young.
It's the size of
generations and whether
or not they express
a partisan preference
and then stick with it.
>> John Haskell: You know,
one thing I wanted to ask Sara
about -- because Sara is one
of the people you
know, who's prominent.
I mean, she's done
the nitty-gritty
on the ground electioneering,
literally the ground game
as well as other
forms of campaigning.
She orchestrated
that as a career
and is still doing some of that.
What's changed in terms of
campaigning and electioneering
over the last two and
a half decades or so
since you've been involved?
And also, does the
campaign matter very much?
You know, how does
campaigning matter?
>> Sara Fagen: So I think the
campaign does still matter
a lot.
It's much harder to have
control over your campaign
as a candidate, particularly
a candidate for Senate
and governor, because of the
way campaign finance laws
have changed.
And the outsized influence
now of third-party groups.
So you can very easily lose
control of your message
if another entity comes in
and spends significantly more
than you and changes
the narrative
of what you want to talk about.
And that happens.
And people often tend
to be very frustrated
with the outside groups in their
own parties because of that.
What's changed overall though
I would say is you know,
I started working in -- my
first campaigns were as a kid.
But my first paid jobs
were in college, you know.
Brancett for governor, and
Dansky who you mentioned earlier
for Congress, did
some work on those.
It was a small business
back then, you know,
like little b business.
You had grassroots
activists, you did some mail,
you organized funding banks.
And those activities still
exist as the lifeblood
of the campaign, but it's
a really big business now.
The amount of money has
grown exponentially.
The amount of sophistication
of communication and targeting,
you know, it takes data
scientists to run a campaign,
particularly at a
statewide level.
But even in most congressional
campaigns, they're now working
with advanced voter
files and analytics.
And like I said, there's teams
of data people involved in them,
and digital targeting.
And you know, it used to
be way more shoe leather.
And there's real
benefits to some of that
and of course there is some
downsides to it as well.
>> John Haskell: Well,
what are you all's answers
to the question of,
do campaigns matter?
>> Elaine Kamarck:
I think they do.
I mean, Sara's right in the
way that they've changed.
But I do think campaigns matter.
And it's interesting, a
lot of times they matter
when somebody screws up.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Okay?
>> Elaine Kamarck: So all
you have to do is think back
to Todd Aikin the
Republican candidate or Senate
in Missouri saying
that you know,
women who were raped
couldn't get pregnant
because their body went into
some kind of altered state
and they couldn't get
pregnant if they were raped.
It's like, "What?"
And you know, that
did it for him.
So you know, the campaign
does matter, particularly
when somebody just
makes a big mistake.
Or when you find out something
about someone that was hidden.
They have a drunk driving
record, they have something else
that they've done in their
past that gets unearthed
in the course of the campaign.
But in terms of arguing over
your Social Security plan,
I just don't see the campaign
really mattering all that much.
>> David Barker:
Yeah, I would say
that campaigns frequently matter
in sort of an indirect way,
in that they make what we refer
to as the fundamentals
matter more, right?
Because it's through campaigning
that people get reminded
of partisanship, right?
So campaigning can
activate partisanship just
by simply reminding the
important targeted voters, "Hey,
like this is the Democratic
or Republican candidate.
This is the person that you're
supposed to be voting for,"
through ads or especially
through microtargeting
and social media, et cetera.
And the second thing
that I'll say --
and this piggybacks
on Sara as well --
is that they matter
in that getting people
to the polls aspect, right?
And again, that's done in a
much more sophisticated way
than it used to be through the
microtargeting and whatnot.
But it's not like you're going
to persuade that many voters
through campaigning, but you
are going to try to make sure
that your people
get to the polls.
And campaigns are a lot better
at that than they used to be.
>> John Haskell: So how
many seats are in play
in the House, David, this year?
Let's get to the fun part.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: We're
going to talk about 2018,
what's going to happen.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: I
might even force them
into a prediction,
but maybe not.
Let's see.
>> David Barker:
No, let's do that.
I'm ready for that.
>> John Haskell:
Straight up, all of you.
We'll start with David.
How many House seats
are in play?
>> David Barker: Roughly 60.
>> John Haskell: Okay.
>> Elaine Kamarck:
I'd say about 70.
>> John Haskell: Okay.
What do you think?
>> Sara Fagen: I'd say 55.
>> John Haskell: 55.
So we're sort of in range here.
And in the Senate, how many?
We'll start with you.
>> Sara Fagen: Six or seven.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck:
I'd say about five.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
I was going to say like if you
really want to be generous,
right, you could
imagine up to 10.
But in reality, I'd
say more like six.
>> John Haskell: Okay,
so we'll get back
to specific things to look at.
But here's a question that --
I think this is a hard one,
so I'm just going to let
anyone who wants to talk to it.
And it's been anticipated
by some of what you said.
Particularly I think
something David said earlier.
The economy is going
great guns right now,
although don't look
at your stocks today.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Right, don't
look at the stock market today.
>> John Haskell:
Don't happen to look
at the Wall Street
Journal today.
And so two things.
They're different but
they're going to play in.
The economy's going great.
You know, unemployment's
like minus three or whatever.
Republicans didn't pick up any
seats in the house in 2016,
in part because their
candidate didn't win a plurality
of the vote.
And they have thus relatively
few vulnerable seats.
I think you got into
that, David,
as compared to say Democrats
had in 2010 after they'd gone
through two cycles of
winning lots of seats.
And they had a lot of people who
should never have been elected.
You know, you get into that
situation, who are going
to be more vulnerable.
Yet, analysts are saying this
year that Republicans are
in deep trouble in the House
and maybe even have a small
chance of losing the Senate.
What is going on here?
>> Sara Fagen: It's a really
interesting phenomenon.
You know, I think there are sort
of some environmental factors
that certainly caused
the House to be in play.
We mentioned earlier the
president's low approval rating.
But you know, what
is highly unusual is
that you have a president
with a low job approval rating
and a really strong economy.
>> David Barker: Yeah, I'm not
sure we've ever seen it before.
>> Sara Fagen: Just to put
into context how strong the
economy is, it's the single --
I've always looked at -- I
sort of learned this working
on the Bush reelect
from another strategist
on the team studying consumer
conference board present
situation index.
You study it, if you look at
the trend line, and over time
since the thing has
been measured,
if an incumbent president
running
for reelection has a trend line
going up, he has been reelected.
And if he has a trend line
going down, he has lost.
And you can look at every
president and you know,
the Reagan and Clinton economies
and the consumer confidence
is high and trending up.
So you look at all the
clusters in the period
of time before their
election, their reelect,
and you of course would see
Clinton and the Reagan economies
up here, you know, the Bush 41
and Carter economies down here.
Well, Trump is over here.
It's really strong right now.
And so I do wonder if that's
going to blunt some of this.
And that he's personally
unpopular, but his job approval
in terms of his actions
in office are higher.
And this is something people
measured in the Clinton years.
People didn't personally like
Bill Clinton because of some
of the antics and the Me
Too stuff before Me Too was
a movement.
But they thought he did a
really good job in office
and they rewarded him for it
and rewarded Democrats for it.
And I think we're going to see
that blunt some Democrat wins.
We also had a significant amount
of retirements as a party.
More retirements out of
this Congress I think
than at any point
since the '30s.
And that's going to --
>> David Barker:
Mostly Republicans.
>> Sara Fagen: Mostly
Republicans.
So it's going to cause
Republicans to lose seats
that had the party been more
organized and kept people
in office, they'd probably
be in a better position
to retain the House today.
>> John Haskell: Elaine, how
do you answer that question?
Or either of you?
>> Elaine Kamarck: I mean,
you're absolutely right.
It really is a conundrum
here, this president.
But what you see in a lot
of the public opinion
polls are people saying,
"We need a Democratic Congress
to check this president."
And their concerns about this
president are not the classic
ones: is he handling
the economy right?
You know, it's not
a policy concern.
It's a concern about frankly
his authoritarian tendencies.
And so people are
worried about democracy.
They're worried about
the norms of the country
because he's been a norm breaker
ever since he got into office.
And he doesn't seek
to unite the country
like most presidents have done.
He's very divisive.
And so I think you have
another issue out there
which is his behavior vis a
vis, the democratic process.
And that's in competition with
the more classic behaviors
that we've studied like how good
the economy is, do you approve
of the way he's conducting
his policies in office?
The way to look at this,
and Sara mentioned this,
was in 1998, that's
one of the few years
where the incumbent president
actually didn't lose seats
but actually gained
seats in a midterm.
And Clinton had been
impeached that year.
He'd been impeached.
>> David Barker:
Which is something
for the Democrats to remember.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Something
He'd been impeached.
He was not convicted
in the Senate.
And what happened was
people made a decision
that they liked what
he was doing
as president even
though the ratings
of him personally were very
low because of his dalliances
with a White House intern.
So that's something
to bear in mind
as we look at what's coming up.
>> David Barker: So
a couple of things
that are different
I think that help
to explain why we've
got this conundrum
of a really strong economy and
a really unpopular president is
that unlike Clinton
where as Sara said,
people didn't necessarily like
him personally, but they thought
that he was doing
well in office,
the median voter
believed that, right?
Independents, right, and even
some Republicans believed
that Clinton was doing
well policy-wise in office.
And why wouldn't they, right?
I mean, he was a right of center
president in a lot of ways.
But people who opposed Trump,
right, basically all Democrats
and a plurality of
independents, right,
don't just dislike
him personally --
although it's impossible
to overstate how much they
dislike him personally, right?
They also think that he
is bad at his job, right?
And so in that way it's
different than Trump, right?
They oppose his policies.
They oppose the tax cuts.
They oppose the immigration
plan.
They oppose pulling out
of the Climate Accord.
They oppose pulling out of Iran.
They oppose sort of
like offending everybody
in Europe, right?
They oppose the shift on trade
and they oppose basically
everything.
They oppose all the deregulation
and everything, right?
We can go on and on
and on and on, right?
And so that's different.
The other thing that is
different is that if you think
about those presidents who were
reelected with strong economies
in the trajectory, in
every one of those cases,
the economy had been
going poorly, right.
And then that new president came
in and things got better, right?
So Reagan came in -- it took
a couple of years, right --
but the economy had been
struggling throughout most
of the '70s and definitely
at the end
of the Carter administration.
It continued to for
a couple of years,
but then it took off, right?
And that fueled Reagan's
popularity.
The same was true, right,
with Clinton, right?
Where the economy had
been strong in the '80s
but we'd had a recession
in the '90s right before
Clinton took office.
Same was true with Obama, right?
We had had the Great Recession
and then Obama comes in
and things slowly tick
up, not fast enough
to anybody's satisfaction.
But things slowly got
better over the course
of his administration.
The difference this time,
right, is that the Trump,
that trend line is
just a continuation.
Instead of going like
this and then like this,
the economy's been going like
this for ten years, right?
Or it's going like this
for eight years prior
to Trump coming in.
And it has continued
to go like this, right?
And so that might explain
that conundrum to some degree.
>> John Haskell: So listen,
we're going to do one sort
of fun question and
then we'll get
to one more substantive question
and then go to your questions.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> John Haskell: The fun one
is, in the next few weeks,
what are the bellweathers?
What are you watching,
either House or Senate?
You know, what would
you tell the audience
to say, "Hey, watch this.
This will give you a sense"?
Anything will give you a sense
of where things are headed?
And then also maybe you could
throw in your prediction.
Who wants to start?
Elaine, why don't you start?
>> Elaine Kamarck: Okay.
Well, all right, I'm going
to watch two Senate races.
I'm going to watch the Heitkamp
race in North Dakota to see
if she bounces back from
her opposition to Kavanaugh
and begins to close that gap.
She has come from behind before.
There's a lot of money
pouring into that state.
So that's possible.
I will also watch
the Texas Senate race
with Bado O'Rourke and Ted Cruz.
Because if Bado O'Rourke
comes within a point or two,
that's a pretty significant
shift, even if he loses.
If he wins, then they're going
to call this not the blue wave,
but they're going to
call it the blue tsunami.
Okay? And that's what
it's going to be.
I'm going to also watch
those California races.
Seven out of the 24 districts
that the Democrats need
to flip the House
are in California.
And California has been
going increasingly blue.
So if those races
all look solid,
then it means Democrats don't
have to pick up that many seats
in other parts of the country.
So watch those California races.
Many of them are in Southern
California, Orange County
which has gone through
a demographic change,
as well as the opposition
to Trump.
So that's what I'm watching.
>> John Haskell:
And your prediction?
>> Elaine Kamarck: I think
the Senate will stay close
and stay in Republican hands.
I think the Democrats
will pick up 30-40 seats
in the House and take the House.
>> John Haskell: David,
you want to go next?
>> David Barker: Sure.
So let me pick up on Texas.
So I grew up in Texas
and people --
and it's easy for me when I
think about the state I grew
up in to imagine Texas
turning blue as being some sort
of crazy, wild-eyed
liberal pipe dream.
But it's important to think
about something in 2016,
which is that Hillary
Clinton lost Texas
by a smaller margin
than she lost Ohio.
And Jared Brown is going to
win by double digits in Ohio.
And Jared Brown is
a very liberal --
>> John Haskell: Senate race.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
He is defending his
seat in the Senate,
very progressive Democrat.
Some would call him shrill.
And he's going to
win easily in a place
that really should be worse
for Democrats now than Texas
if you take 2016 as
the marker on that.
And so what that means, I'll say
that Jared Brown is more
progressive than Bado O'Rourke.
And so I don't actually
think that it will be as much
of a shocker if O'Rourke
is able to win in Texas.
To me it would be a bigger
shock if Bredesen were
to win in Tennessee, right?
And so in terms of other
things to pay attention to,
in addition to Texas and in
addition to North Dakota --
although I've already kind of
written Heidi Camp off there --
I would also pay
attention to Missouri
where Claire McCaskill
is in deep trouble,
and probably outside of
Heitkamp, the Democrat who's
in the biggest trouble.
And I would say -- well,
I'll leave that alone.
Yeah, and I guess Tennessee.
We'll see if the Taylor Swift
effect makes any difference.
>> John Haskell: What are you
doing for your predictions?
>> David Barker: Oh.
So in the House, we're going
to call it a blue tide,
not a blue wave, for a
whole host of reasons,
some of which we touched on
here and Sara alluded to.
It's harder for blue waves
to happen than red waves.
And so I'm going to say 30
seats in the House and I'm going
to say that Democrats lose
a couple in the Senate
and they win a couple
in the Senate,
and it evens right back out.
So we stay right where we are.
>> John Haskell: Sara,
what are you looking at?
>> Sara Fagen: Well, I'll just
continue on the Texas theme.
I think you know, three
weeks ago, four weeks ago,
Ted Cruz would have won
by three or four points
and I think today he'll
win by six or seven points,
because I think it's
still a Republican state.
Although it has gotten
increasingly blue.
But it's still a
republican state
and I think the hyper-partisan
nature
of the Supreme Court fight
really manifested itself
in places like Missouri,
North Dakota but also Texas.
I also think Bado
O'Rourke, you know,
while he may be less
progressive than Jared Brown,
he's quite progressive
for Texans
and I think Ted Cruz has got
a real campaign apparatus now
in motion on this.
Maybe the weren't
taking him as serious
as they should have
been earlier.
You know, I'm also watching
these House districts.
My view -- and this
could change,
because passions were inflamed
and the whole nation was focused
on the Supreme Court and
four weeks is an eternity
in an election cycle.
But assuming Republicans
are now more enthusiastic
and Democrats were
basically already
at 11 before the
Supreme Court hearing,
they don't have much
room to grow.
Republicans have a lot of room
to grow and they've grown.
And so I look at all these
House seats that are plus-7,
6 or 7% Republican advantage
in the partisan registration
or the partisan identification
in the district
that were lean Republican seats
or in some cases
even swing seats.
Like a seat like Indie Bar,
a seat like Kentucky where --
that's maybe not
the best example
because there's a lot
of colleges there.
There are a number of really
what should be Republican
districts that were "in play".
I don't think those
are in play anymore.
So I still think from a
prediction perspective,
just based on the math,
there's so many swing seats
that are Republican
and there are
so many Republican retirements
and you have a president
under 40.
It's probably very difficult for
Republicans to retain control.
But I would have said three
or four weeks ago Democrats
might pick up 40 seats,
and I think they probably
pick up just enough
to get them over the hump.
>> David Barker: Or
25-30, in that range.
>> Sara Fagen: Yeah,
something like that.
And the Senate, I think
Republicans probably --
you know, maybe net
lose one only.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> Sara Fagen: And maybe
not, maybe lose none.
Yeah.
>> John Haskell: And so the
last thing I want to ask
about is there's
been a lot of talk --
and we'll start with you, Sara,
that this is potentially
the year of the woman.
What does that actually
mean in tangible terms?
I mean, to the extent
that might be true,
what does that mean
in tangible terms?
>> Sara Fagen: Well, first
of all, it was the year
of the woman long before there
was a Supreme Court opening.
And the reason it was
the year of the woman
in part is certainly in the
aftermath of the 2016 election,
some women in this country felt
like Donald Trump's behavior
toward women was not properly
addressed in the election.
And they felt very
emboldened to get involved.
There's also a cultural
movement that spans sports
and entertainment and the news
industry, and across the board,
where appropriate workplace
conduct had a big light shone
on it.
And it needed to.
And it was a good thing.
Just to put some practical
numbers around it though,
if you look at the number of
women who are running for office
in the house, you
know, I think 50%
of the nominees are
Democrats in the House.
50% of the Democrat
nominations are women.
You've had significantly --
I have actually this chart.
It's going to be
really hard to see it,
but you've had basically
450 women run for the House.
And while many of them are
Democrats, you've also had
over 100 Republican women run
which is significantly more
than any year in history.
It's true in the Senate as well.
You've had almost 50
women run for the Senate.
Most of them are Democrats.
But you've had almost 20
Republican women run as well.
So it's across the board
and it scales in proportion
to the percentage of
people previously involved.
And it's a good thing.
And I think women getting
involved more actively
in the political process
will help dramatically,
actually move back to a place
where we have conversation
and bipartisanship.
>> John Haskell: Both of you
have been involved in politics,
Elaine even longer than Sara.
What's your perspective on it?
>> Elaine Kamarck: Thanks, that
really makes me feel great.
>> John Haskell: By
a month or two, yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck:
Yeah, by a month.
>> John Haskell: But what's
your perspective on that?
>> Elaine Kamarck: There's
going to be more women
in the Congress, no doubt about
it, and the number of women
who are activated this
time is truly amazing.
So there's been a
generational shift here.
The scholarship on women
in politics is that one
of the big differences is that
women always waited to be asked.
Okay? Well, guess what?
This new generation is
not waiting to be asked.
They're acting like men.
They're just looking in
the mirror and saying,
"Hello, Madame Senator."
Okay? You know, the
joke used to always be
that any 28-year-old man in the
country would look at himself
and go, "Hello, Mr. President."
And a 28-year-old woman
would say, "Oh dear,
I could never do that."
So you know, this
seems to be going away
with the new generation,
thank God.
And I also think, and we see
this in all the races we've seen
with the special elections,
there is an enormous gender
gap between the parties.
I mean, the Republican
party is the man's party.
The Democratic party
is the woman's party,
just to be simple about it.
And there's just lots more
women voting for Democrats.
The hope for the Democrats
is suburban Republican women
crossing over because
they don't like Trump.
Remember, the day after the
president was inaugurated,
you had a woman's march
on Washington that was all
about opposing that
new president.
So something's happened here.
I don't know how long this will
exist, you know what I mean?
I don't know how
permanent it is.
But there's definitely
a big gender split
in our politics these days,
and I've never seen
anything like it.
>> John Haskell: So
roughly what is that split?
What is that gap?
Do you know the numbers, David?
>> David Barker:
It's like 20 points.
Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck:
Yeah, 20 points is huge.
Now, if it's 20 points
evenly, right,
it sort of doesn't
make any difference,
except there are
slightly more women
than men in the world, okay?
And women have higher
turnout rates than men do.
That began to happen
in the '80s.
Now I'm showing my age now
in spite of what I said,
so when I was a baby political
scientist, women did not turn
out as much as men did.
And the reason was
that you still had
in the electorate women who
were socialized in an era
when they didn't
have the vote, okay?
And even when they got
the vote, it wasn't sort
of something women
were supposed to do.
Well, you know, fast
forward 30 years
and they're all dead, okay?
And they're not in the
electorate anymore.
So you don't have any
generations of women
who think it's weird that
women should vote, okay?
So this has been -- so now
you have slightly more women
and you have much
higher turnout of women.
And this makes a
big, big difference.
You know, the big
problem journalists have
in election analysis is they
always look at percentages
and they forget about
the arithmetic, okay?
So guess what?
Having a 1-point advantage
amongst 51% of the electorate,
that's big numbers, right?
Whereas having a 1-point
advantage among 8%
of the electorate is not.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: And so,
there's just a lot
of women around.
>> John Haskell: So you're going
to have the last word before
we get to a few questions.
>> David Barker: A few
final things to say on that.
First of all, with the turnout
differential between men
and women, Elaine is
completely right on that.
However, until this year it
appears, right, the gap in terms
of turnout of women turn
out more, was much more true
in presidential years
than in midterms, right?
And so women tended to turn
out much higher rates than men
in presidential years, and
then maybe like slightly higher
than men in midterm years or
even to men in midterm years.
Whereas this year, right,
all the indicators are
that women will turn out
at higher rates than men
in similar rates that they
do in presidential elections.
And so that's really
significant.
The other thing I'll say,
just with respect to the year
of the woman is that anybody
who thinks that Nancy Pelosi is
in trouble is probably
wrong, right?
I mean, I think this is going
to be the wrong year, right,
to oust Nancy Pelosi as speaker.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Can
I just say, if Pelosi,
Hoyer and Klieberd
deliver a Democratic House
with a significant margin,
none of the mare
going anyplace, okay?
This is all nonsense.
>> John Haskell: Okay,
so indicate to me
if you're interested
in asking a question.
We have the lady
right there, Linda.
You want to give Linda --
>> Thank you.
Mention was made of
the essential role
that data scientists play
in election campaigns today.
I've always been curious
though, what happened
with the data science when
they predicted Clinton's win
for the presidential campaign?
Can you explain that?
>> Sara Fagen: Yeah, so
it's a good question.
And I think you're really asking
a question about the polling.
And you know, a couple thoughts.
One, the polling actually wasn't
wrong on the national election.
It showed Hillary Clinton
winning by a few points
and she did win the popular
vote by almost two points.
She did not of course
win key electoral states
like Michigan and Wisconsin.
And at least in one of those
states, I think it as Wisconsin,
she didn't even set
foot in the entire time.
And the polling on some
of those states was off.
But it was also because
there wasn't very much of it.
>> David Barker: Right.
>> Sara Fagen: So there was
nothing recent, you know?
And the Trump campaign was just
very sophisticated in playing
in those states and playing
quite quietly until the very end
when they played quite
publicly and won them.
And they played the
electoral college very well.
There is a problem with polling:
it tends to be more accurate
nationally and harder to predict
in states because
of the sample size.
It's increasingly difficult
to get people on a landline.
And fundamentally polling still
works if it's done properly.
And if it's a mix of sort
of internet, landline
and increasingly cell
phone technology --
and what happens and why a
lot of news polls are off is
because -- not all of them.
Some of them are
still quite good.
Some of them are really off,
particularly the auto dials --
is they don't do cell phones,
or they don't do a
big enough percentage
of people with cell phones.
Because it's really
expensive to call cell phones
because the laws prevent
research companies --
if you're calling
someone on a cell phone,
you have to manually dial it.
You can't use an auto
dialer for cell phones.
So it dramatically
raises the cost.
And as a result of it, they
skimp on the cell phones
and they get too
high a proportion
of whatever population,
whether it's poor or older
or some combination, that
only has a landline telephone.
>> John Haskell: Of
course Sara's right
that the polls reflected Hillary
winning the popular vote,
but the better data scientists
did say Trump could win.
>> David Barker: Right.
>> John Haskell: It's like
with anything on the internet.
You're bombarded
with information.
Are you getting the
better information?
Can you separate
wheat from chaff?
>> David Barker: Haskell,
you're the moderator.
>> John Haskell: Yeah.
>> David Barker: I want to
remind you you're the moderator.
>> John Haskell: You were
about to say that too?
[ Laughter ]
>> David Barker: I did
want to quickly just say
that not only were the
data scientists as opposed
to the pollsters or the pundits,
the real data scientists
did give Trump about a one
in three chance of winning.
Which you know, if you
flip a bunch of coins,
one in three happens
quite a bit, right?
And so that was the deal there.
And also I will say that part
of the reason why he was able
to win unexpectedly in
Wisconsin, Pennsylvania
and Michigan was because of the
microtargeting done as a result
of some of the data
science that was done
by that campaign
in those states.
The final thing I'll say about
the polling though is that part
of the reason why it's hard
to get good polls in states is
that in addition to it
being really expensive
to call cell phones, hardly
anybody has an area code
that is associated with where
they actually live, right?
>> Elaine Kamarck: Yeah.
>> David Barker: And
so that's like fine
for a national poll, right?
You think you're calling
somebody in Wisconsin.
In reality you're
calling somebody
in California and all that.
So anyway.
>> John Haskell: That gentleman
right there, I think -- yeah.
Why don't you get the
microphone for a second?
>> I was interested in
some of your thoughts
about these new approaches
to elections.
I had read about this approach
called right choice voting.
And I was interested in what
you all think about that.
>> John Haskell: Elaine, do
you know anything about that?
>> Elaine Kamarck: You know,
I think right choice
voting is very interesting.
I think when I first heard
about it back in the Dark Ages,
it was before computers.
So you know, it was kind
of mind-boggling how you
would get an accurate count.
These days you really could
use right choice voting.
It think it's very interesting
as a possibility in primaries.
>> David Barker: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Where you
tend not to have a binary,
and the differences between
the candidates are not all
that great.
But other than the state of
Maine which just tried it,
nobody else seems
very interested in it.
And when I talked to members
of Congress or I talked
to elected officials about
it, they sort of stare
at you blankly like, "Huh?"
So I think the uncertainty
about it -- it's like anything.
When you change electoral
systems, it's the incumbents
who have to change it.
And it's the incumbents
who are most fearful of it
because after all they
won in the old system.
So it's a good idea.
I mean, it's not
at all a bad idea.
Its just one that I don't
see happening very quickly.
>> John Haskell: We're going
to one more question over here
and then we'll have an
opportunity for people
to meet the panel
during the reception.
Does Kathy have a question?
>> Thank you very much for
a very interesting panel.
I have one question that goes
back to the pig in the python.
The millennial group, I
didn't realize it was so big
as you just said it is.
How likely is that group,
based on your knowledge
and experience, to shift
its political affiliations
as they move through
the age cycle?
Are they going to go from
left to right to left,
or just stay wherever they are?
Just wondering what
you think about that.
>> John Haskell: Sara's
eager to address that.
It's a great question.
>> Sara Fagen: It
is a great question
and I actually considered
jumping in
and saying historically,
as young people get older
and buy homes and pay
taxes and have you know,
other more complex
responsibilities in life,
they have tended to
become conservative.
Now you know, I think society
is changing quite dramatically
and quite rapidly, so I don't
think that's guaranteed.
And certainly some members
of young generations would
always stay more liberal
or more conservative based
on how they were raised.
But you know, that's a
generation that's not
particularly interested
in owning things.
They're very comfortable
in a sharing economy.
Elaine mentioned, I would
agree, that they don't
like Republicans or Democrats.
They don't particularly assign
themselves to any label.
I think what's probably more
likely than them becoming --
you know, some of them will move
around over time
and based on issues.
But I think what's more likely
politically is that we're going
to see more parties
in this country.
And we're certainly going to
see independent candidates
and more meaningful
independent candidates.
It's very difficult
to get on the ballot
in a presidential
race for example.
But social media to a
degree makes that easier
and makes it easier
for people to organize.
And I think over
time, you're likely
to see a more diverse
political system
than necessarily a younger voter
saying, "Okay, I was a liberal
in my 20s and 30s and now I'm a
conservative in my 40s and 50s."
You know, I don't
think in 20 years
when those folks are older
we'll be in the same paradigm.
>> John Haskell: I think we have
a topic for a whole other panel.
>> Sara Fagen: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Yeah, right,
a topic for a whole other panel.
>> John Haskell: David
has a word to say on that.
>> David Barker: Yeah, so
one thing that I think,
aside from party
identification and whether
or not people switch,
I think that one thing
that is unlikely is that these
millennials will become more
culturally conservative
over time.
I think it may be the case that
as they get older and own things
and whatever, that
they may become more
economically conservative.
I think that it's unlikely that
they are going to become --
well, some of them may
become more religious,
but the general trend
towards secularization
in society is not
likely to reverse itself.
The trend toward more tolerance
toward sexual minorities is not
likely to reverse itself.
The trend toward greater
tolerance toward racial
and ethnic diversity is not
likely to reverse itself.
And so what I expect to
see is that the culture war
that we've been living in
for the past 40 or 50 years
in another 20 years may
actually finally culminate.
And the big things that we fight
about politically may go back
to what they were in the
'40s, '50s and '60s which was
about like the free market
versus the welfare state.
I would anticipate in 2050
if we had a panel like this,
those will be the things that
people are fighting about,
and not race, not
gender, not religion
like we have been
for the past 40.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Let me
give a contrary view, okay?
People who cast their first vote
in 1932 for Franklin Roosevelt,
that generation by and
large stayed Democratic
until they died.
>> DV: Yeah.
>> Elaine Kamarck: Okay?
There is an imprinting
question that goes on.
And we know this
from political --
there's a whole study of this
called political sociology,
okay?
We know that one of the things
about the maligned gen X-ers is
their political experience was
Ronald Reagan.
They tend to be Republicans.
So there is something about
whether or not you come
into politics in with some
sort of dramatic election.
Certainly, '32 was a
big, dramatic election.
2008 because of the first
African American president was a
dramatic election.
So there is some evidence
that generations actually take
their partisanship with them,
even though they change and
they get more conservative
on economic questions
or cultural questions.
That there's an imprinting.
And I would send you
to a big literature
on political sociology
and cohort analysis
which shows this for
American history.
>> John Haskell: I can't
help but point out the irony
that Reagan himself
voted for FDR.
[ Laughter ]
Four times.
Four times, actually.
Thank you all very much, and
American University for help.
[ Applause ]